pour ces deux demoiselles catherine et
françoise dorléac le tout paris hier
soir avait les yeux de jacques demy car
après les parapluies de cherbourg
il vient de réaliser avec michel legrand
les demoiselles de rochefort
jacques-demy vous devenez un spécialiste
de la comédie musicale parce que j'aime
bien ce qui sort des sentiers battus
avec les sentiers sont pas intéressants
ce qui est tout à fait fascinant c'est
là c'est de chercher quelque chose de
nouveau
je crois enfin des attaches dans la
création précisément de faire des choses
différentes et par exemple le film que
j'avais fait précédemment était un film
plus tôt
grave sérieux et j'avais envie de
trouver un sentiment de joie comme ça
qui fait que le spectateur trouve un
encouragement une une détente à sourire
et voilà en face au début du film on
peut dire que c'est la première comédie
musicale française
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu des tentatives
quand même se fait vraiment je me dis à
très longtemps est enfin william ça vous
n'avez pas fait de comédie musicale en
france
est ce que vous comptez poursuivre avec
avec votre ami michel legrand dans cette
voie je ne sais pas je ne peux pas vous
dire pour l'instant parce que c'est un
tel travail j'ai été longtemps sur ce
sur ce film que maintenant je suis
vide et sans idées et sans jugement sur
tout et j'ai besoin de faire le point et
puis de réfléchir et puis je sais qu'une
petite mécanique se mettra en route et
que automatiquement je trouverais ce que
j'ai à faire
alors ce sera peut-être un autre musical
effectivement catherine deneuve le matin
comme ça après le triomphal succès du
film hier soir qu'est ce qui se passe si
vous ressentez je veux c'est un petit
peu enfin pour vous avez fêté le succès
oui d'abord parce que le film a commencé
assez tard et quantité
j'aimerais que vous ne parliez de
jacques demy cas vous êtes l'enfant
chéri de jacques demy on peut le dire
et moi je m'excuse mon intervention
chéri pas forcément j'aimerais que vous
me parlez lui comme moi c'est quelqu'un
de très tendre très de très doux et très
violent à la fois de très sûr de lui
c'est très ambitieux c'est quelqu'un qui
est bien qu'ils aient mettre au bord de
la mer qui a vous au niveau de la mer
pour vie je crois d'ailleurs il a une
maison à moutier il souvent et qui a
besoin du vent la mer vous travaillez
aussi c'est pour ça qu'il fait toujours
des filles dans les ports